there's a republican congressman who is
reportedly missing in afghanistan
because he's on a
action hero like mission
to individually just personally rescue a
family of four or five
i this is a real story
he has attempted to get into afghanistan
two other times once through greece and
once i believe through tajikistan
and both times he was turned away and he
apparently got into a fight with the
embassy because they wouldn't let him
through he's just trying to go in with a
bunch of cash to get out of afghanistan
and uh but now the reports are he did
make it in we don't really know how we
don't know if they're true or not
obviously there's a lot of a lot more
questions than answers
but the reports are that he did make it
in we don't know how he's got a bunch of
money and he's just gonna buy and shoot
his way out of afghanistan and save this
family
this is awesome this is great
i get why the embassies turned him away
and said no you can't just go on a
one-man rogue mission into afghanistan
but
one i'm glad that we've got a little
do-it-yourselfer here who's actually
going to take matters into his own hands
and two
this shows you
the incompetence of the bureaucracy of
the blob the state department and
everyone else over there
even a u.s congressman can't get answers
even when a united states elected
congressman calls and says hey get this
family out
he can't get anywhere so he's got to
take matters into his own hands
it shows you how little faith we have in
the the deep state the official
washington you know the or rather the
the permanent washington the elected
people come and go but the permanent
bureaucracy the permanent government
remains
and not even the elected guys can get
answers out of them
i'm glad you like that vid i need you to
do me a favor one for two favors okay
one leave a comment
whatever i don't care what the comment
is just leave it you know hey michael
nice hair man i say what's going on
michael thank you for doing that second
take out your phone
open up your podcast app here i'll get
mine up open up your podcast app
go to the okay whatever apple podcast or
spotify or stitch or whatever click it
okay you're there all right type in the
michael knowles show
all right you got it search you see
they're probably going to suppress the
results but you know what the show is
you click it
click subscribe
i appreciate that i appreciate you thank
you
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]